this book rational mail
who who agreed with you who disagreed
with you who said
i i
agree with what he has to say dude the
guy is full of he has no clue what
he's talking about look
you write books you're going to have
people from both sides absolutely who
liked it we still do still do it's
mostly guys that hate it yes
interesting yeah uh okay i'm gonna i'll
tell you a really quick funny story here
when i was writing the second book which
is the preventative medicine it's a
timeline and everything that you know
what to expect from women at certain uh
phases of maturity
um i i started that book with an
introduction because i had a guy relate
this story to me that he was reading the
first book rational mail and he was uh
he was there you know checking it out on
his couch or something his girlfriend's
wife whoever came in and said you know
the rational male who's there's no
rational male and he's laughing at him
she's like give me that i'll decide you
know what this is all about girl read it
yeah the girl read it she grabbed it
from him and it took her like maybe uh
three or four days to to read it she
just like ate it up she comes back to
the guy at the end of the week and she
tosses it back to me she says everything
in that book is correct and you
shouldn't know any of it
and that was that and you shouldn't
because it gives away the game it gives
away the it gives away the uh the
mechanics the underpinnings of like
what's going on
um you know sort of the the dance
between men and women and that's that's
when i get hate from from guys it's
usually because they're they don't know
how to apply this
or it conflicts with a very deeply held
ideology like their ego invested in this
what we call you know the blue pill
ideas where it's like this is what
you've been taught from from a from a
societal perspective from a western
societal perspective this is how men are
this is how women are and this is what
you can expect from them and then
they'll get into that point where they
have um
or they have that bad breakup or they
have that bad divorce or they're going
through some kind of trauma and it's
only at that point where they go they
start questioning about you know
was what i taught you know for real or
not and so
this you know the work that i do kind of
steps in and fills in those blanks so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you